the outer ear includes the pinna which
collects sound waves and the ear canal
which transports sound waves to the
eardrum a paper-thin layer of tissue
separating the outer and middle ear
sound waves caused the eardrum to
vibrate which in turn vibrates three
tiny bones inside the middle ear called
the malleus incus and stapes which pass
the sound vibrations along to the inner
ear the inner ear translates vibrations
into electrical signals which are picked
up by the auditory nerve sent to the
brain and interpreted as sound this
complex process occurs instantly
allowing us to hear the sounds around us
as they have been
[Music]